[Musique]
justement venant sont à ses attaques à
ce qui fait dire tout à l'heure à
raymond barre que ce suicide était la
conséquence de certaines ignominie et
d'une grande bassesse à ce qui a fait
dire aussi à jacques chaban delmas qu'on
pourrait presque parler d'assassinât
tous concentre vraisemblement autour
d'un dossier celui de l'achat d'un
terrain et de la construction de la
résidence secondaire de robert boulin à
ramatuelle près de saint-tropez paul le
faire nous explique maintenant les
aspects techniques devaient les voir
assez complexe de ce dossier révélé par
la presse il ya une quinzaine de jours
environ
cette maison de vacances est sans doute
devenu le cauchemar de robert boulin
mais elles n'existaient pas en 1967
lorsque la sphère du val de bois à
débuter à cette date là un promoteur
henry tournée et des propriétaires de 36
hectares ramatuelle pour lesquelles il
obtient un permis de construire un
lotissement
mais comme henri tournet tarder à
construire un lotissement le permis
devient caduque et une nouvelle
réglementation en 68 lui interdisent
édifier le projet dans cette affaire il
semble d'ailleurs que henry tournée est
toujours cherché à faire pression sur
robert boulin pour obtenir malgré la
nouvelle réglementation à nouveau permis
de construire pour son lotissement
toujours est il qu'en janvier 73 henry
tournée vans la plus grosse partie du
terrain soit une trentaine d'hectares à
trois hommes d'affaires normand qui
croyait distille encore qu'on pouvait
toujours construire sur ce terrain et
même avec un projet de lotissement
cette vente n'est pas enregistrés au
bureau des hypothèques de draguignan
pour des raisons qui ne sont pas très
claires mais dès ce moment là les trois
acheteurs normands se croit propriétaire
du terrain alors que henry tournée
prenant prétexte que cette vente n'a pas
été enregistrée revanche une nouvelle
fois le terrain à une société suisse
holy tour dont on dit par ailleurs qu'il
serait l'actionnaire majoritaire
rien ne prouve que robert boulin et
d'été au courant de cette double vente
lorsqu en 1960 il achète à la société
suisse holy tour 2 hectares à cet
endroit pour y construire une villa et
le ministre respectant la nouvelle
réglementation présente un projet et
obtient son permis de construire et
ces raisons de vacances mais les trois
acheteurs normand conteste tout de suite
la vente et par le fait même la validité
du permis de construire obtenu par
robert boulin en 1975 sur plainte de la
chambre des notaires de la manche
une information est ouverte qui débouche
après quelques péripéties qui débouche
le 12 juin 79 sur deux inculpations
l'inculpation de m groult le notaire qui
a enregistré qui a accepté d'enregistrer
la vente entre henri tournée et holly
tour et sur l'inculpation aussi d'henri
tournée accusé d'avoir vendu deux fois
le même terrain
c'est le notaire des acquéreurs qui m'a
demandé ainsi qu'un jeu breton pas
demandé de revendre cette ces terrains
là les tickets vendus par acte non
publiée qui m'a demandé vers dans une
cité du tout parce qu'il pensait que
cela pouvait régulariser l'opération
depuis 1976 robert boulin tenter de
savoir à l'air à l'aide d'un notaire de
kokkola s'il était réellement
propriétaire de son terrain si sa
parcelle faisait partie des 30 hectares
vendue une première fois henri tourner
autre d'acheteurs normand il semble
qu'une étude de géomètre établi le 13
janvier 118 et révélé que le terrain
boulin était en effet vendu deux fois
par henri tournée il semble aussi que
les trois acheteurs normand et
refusaient d'échanger le terrain moulin
contre un terrain libre l'information
l'anc est en cours démontrera si
l'ensemble l'opération et avait été
portée à la connaissance du ministre du
travail
il en est en tout cas toujours défendre
[Musique]